hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
beta turns so beta turns are one type of
secondary structure found in protein in
my earlier videos we have talked about
other
secondary structures such as alpha
helices and beta pleated sheet
if you miss those you can find their
link in the i button
now let me tell you that protein
structure could have different
levels starting from primary structure
then secondary structure then tertiary
and quaternary structures
and we are now focusing on the secondary
structures
among the secondary structures the most
common ones are alpha helices and beta
plated sheet
now here beta turns are kind of ignored
let's talk about things but in this
video we would try to highlight their
structural features their importance etc
so stay tuned till the end of this video
in fact one third of the structural
elements of a
globular protein is actually beta turn
so beta turn is not an uncommon
structure in terms of a protein
now let me tell you that these beta
terms could be a part
of supersecondary structure or super
secondary motif
such as shown here they consist of
generally
four amino acid residues so they are
very simple
in terms of structure now there could be
glycine and proline
found in these kind of structures both
proline
and glycine increase the flexibility and
hence they are
generally found in beta terms and
remember they were absent
from alpha helices now glycine and
proline
can be present both or might not i mean
one might be present and other might not
be present
here the four residues are named as i i
plus
1 2 and 3 where there is a hydrogen bond
exist between the carbonyl oxygen of ith
residue
and the amino group of i plus 3rd
residue
and this is major for the stability of
this beta turn
now let me remind you that proline are
generally
not found in alpha helices and if
proline is present it would create a
kink in the alpha helices ah bend in the
alpha helices and which would
destabilize the structure but these kind
of proline residues or glycine residues
are
essential for formation of beta turns
where flexibility and bending
is the property which is required now
there could be different
types of beta turn and these
nitty-gritty details
depends upon the phi and the psi angle
of i plus 1 and i plus 2 residues
so here is a list of i plus one and i
plus two residues phi
and psi angle based on that there are
four categories
of beta turn type one type two type one
dash and two dash
now in a ramachandran plot you can see
these
beta terms in different location so the
type
1 would be found here in the bottom part
where in the type 2 would be found in
the upper quadrant
so and this differences are due to
inverted peptide bond so those
differences occurs due to different phi
and psi
angle that is why they are placed at a
different location
along the ramachandran plot so that was
all about
beta turns it was a very quick and short
video i hope you like this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe thank you